I am pleased to have one of my good
friends right here yeah on the program
michael irvin how are you I'm doing well
right now it's the truth when I say this
now cuz so many times you hear people oh
he's my good friend he's my good friend
yeah you were at my wedding Yeah right
you were at my wedding
11 years ago cuz you worked with Suzy
back in the Fox Sports days right and I
guess what she did she run into you in
the street in New York like two days
before let me know about the wedding I
was like oh really I said eight I'm
coming I'm in man I want to be there and
marriage it was so great cuz you're
right you know and when you work with
people people start saying all they're
saying that cavero on TV you know and to
be at your wedding and then years later
if you gave me the experience of my life
to be at your baby name yes yeah Romo
yeah that happened and I taught it cuz
rich asked me to speak the closing
remarks to his baby naming ceremony even
though I'm not Jewish is not her being
or her win the greatest thing I've ever
witnessed and I talked about a million
times since well and and you know and
we'll get to football in a second but
yes you know like for the baby naming
for my baby daughter who was born to
August yes incredible how long that's
been it's been too long yeah yeah she's
over a year now and so but we did it in
October last year's it's coming on the
one-year anniversary this and the rabbi
said that there's somebody who could in
my ceremony who can speak at the very
end who was the guest speaker now
obviously we have close family members
and see that but I turned to my wife and
I'm like there's only one person to do
it and it's Michael Irvin and she said
done and you gave the most impassioned
about family and what it means and and
you were you're the man every chest
I believe
you know divine order and I believe
everything happens for a reason
me running into Superman being at that
wedding and then us here working years
later years later and you're getting the
seed because you see me at the games
that my passion for fathers and sons
yeah you take pictures stop them on the
streets and write and take pictures on
Twitter that's at Michael Irvin ad it's
all you'll see is pictures of me with
fathers and sons it's a commitment from
the father that he'll stay on his post
and it's a commitment from the son when
he becomes a father he's going to stay
on his post in an old film from my Hall
of Fame speech after I spoke at the Hall
of Fame and talked about where I felt
that I have come up short with my sons
and I prayed that give me strength
moving forward man so many men came up
to me that's why that was so important
because that gave me the completion the
other side of it and I think all
cultures Michael I told African
Americans we need to start doing this to
give a route to our kids and that was
again so I just wanted to give a little
backstory there because oh he's my
friend but we it's the truth so thank
you for being here number one yep number
two we talked I've mentioned how in the
meeting and our morning meeting today
talking about the number of
hall-of-famers that could be in the
stadium tonight right right and we how
we mentioned five you think luck and
water off to the start that could wind
up in Canton I'll no doubt it does right
and then Reggie Wayne and Andre Johnson
from to you from the you just like you
and Vinatieri
what about what about the original you
know let's get it right now yeah that's
we say it before guys you raise your
head checkers - gotta get a chair I mean
in this building for the Patriots he
kicked one through the uprights to beat
the Carolina Panthers what what do you
for those out there might think that
Reggie Wayne is not one why do you go
out and throw his name into that mix the
numbers definitely supportive but what
what about Reggie and you watch them you
see how a man has
progressed through his career and what
Reggie Wayne is reg Wayne was a beast on
the outside for years playing with paid
men and as years got annoying he came
inside and altered his game to make way
for the young and teach him how to play
the game and drew luck he's an
incredible incredible player his
durability the numbers like you say
definitely says so he's a leader he's a
guided not he didn't just play on a team
to put up numbers he lay at that team he
does have a ring and he's in a spot that
Andrew Luck knows where to find him
everywhere where everywhere there are
other young guys remember what last year
was heard when we got to see him on
Thursday Night Football and he was sort
of coach Wayne standing on the sidelines
remember we saw him right and he was and
he was T Y Hilton all those kids that
whose names escaped many football fans
because of Howard on the arm he was yeah
he was and he's he's as good as they
come Andre Johnson spoke about this with
John McClain before why he's not as
productive this year as in previous
years he said votes the quarterback what
where do you stand on that fun well and
I believe it does have something to do
with it you know III know what it's like
to have that one solid quarterback to
play with for a number of years in a
relationship that you build with that
quarterback and he had built a
relationship with Matt Sean and so now
the new guy comes in and Ryan
Fitzpatrick then and some things alter
but now I don't don't fool yourself also
it it also has something to do with your
little dust-up they had at the beginning
of the season which is what they oh yeah
oh now now now you we can't let you hold
us hostage anymore we're going with the
young now because that you know when you
start that kind of stuff in his head
right now oh it's everywhere rich if you
you don't get out of that kind of stuff
when you are a guy that gives everything
you have to an organization the only
thing that really gets you over that
hump gets to come out of this season
with the winter season that ends up in
the playoffs and everybody I kiss and
make up and be good and stuff like that
but but it lingers through the season no
kidding
oh these are emotional players man alpha
males I call them
everybody on the field alpha males Manny
you're telling a guy that you're not as
important in the beginning of the season
with the money and then you're saying it
on the field with get with him getting
less passes so yeah there's no doubt I'm
sure it's still me how could it's look
how good night let's wanted the best now
but let me say this to you now daddy's
still why Andre Johnson is all of famer
rich because he's never had those Hall
of Fame quarterbacks and his numbers
still says oh my god oh my god I'm his
numbers are ridiculous for what he's had
with him but luck lots of beasts just
the beast the best the best and and he
is going to be no doubt the new
prototypical quarterback that we will
look for Martineau having seen Russell
Wilson on Monday Night Football doing
what he did now here's the next
nationally televised game and you put
those you group those two guys together
that's a whole new world we have right
there and Richie you you be careful with
this thing because if we see these two
in the Super Bowl oh it's the worst they
get word from Peyton Manning a Tom Brady
but we could lose we will be on to the
new frontier I'll be a mess Russell
Wilson in Andrew Luck it'd be worse for
them to cuz there they wouldn't be any
way to people soon you know when that
kills them more than anything else don't
go anywhere Michael Irvin's here with us
he's gonna be hanging me with me here
and as soon as we're done we're gonna
walk about 300 yards that way to the
Thursday Night Football set for our NFL
Network night job with one they are
watching the Rich Eisen show from the
Houston Texas so so ready go you got to
go for that that Irving not there
yeah they want me to they want they want
to try it all right well you you go you
go fit now
oh is that 10 yeah you got you have life
but you always go spread come see you
try to cope right I've went through
nodded without I go fool because I don't
want so you're doing leaking out the
side alright so here we go or I'm gonna
wanted to have so I got a new one okay
oh you got to time it so I just youth in
the top youth in the top yeah you will
use wide open the Windsor goes one time
under no right yeah and then and then
around then I go back around all right
you like that and then you let me see
this man rich how far down the list were
Brockman and I on the baby David
ceremony if my couldn't very far down
the baby named Mike wasn't available
week but I'll tell you what this is
bucket list item right here Michael
Arvin giving me a Michael Irvin table
yeah I mean China no that's funny I've
never done it this way I've never done
it rich you have to go big tie on the
show tonight
yes stop my waistline is definitely not
accepted in the commercial break you
know it looks good I guess and then not
right but the back part went so long
that I look like Stan Laurel or a hearty
good on you what you call the Windsor
does what do you think is it look good
on me
Prince III think it's great style and
especially if you are not taking off the
coat what you do is give more color
around the neck it really pops your
color your vest on baby yeah it really
does
yeah well I'm gonna put the jacket on at
the end of this conversation to end the
show so you'll see that it'll look fine
yeah TV when the coat closes right look
out and now what you do you get the
color up in the tie now usually what I
do you know rich I tie my tie so it
falls right at my waistline yeah see
like right at my waistline because I I
don't want you know it won't waste my
comes in like that and I like it like I
do like it you're great you're cowboys
in Seattle sir
yes what do you think nobody thinks
you're gonna come out with that win you
know yeah that nobody nationally thinks
that they're gonna go and take care of
their 12 in
in Seattle you know that's right yeah
that's a scary one too
you know but but now listen if any if
you can beat Seattle in Seattle you're
going to have to do it with the run game
Dallas has that well and you got a
silence that crowd with the run game and
I don't know if you can ever sighs well
gates took care of him and see in San
Diego right so what what about Whitman
without using Whitley yeah a win has the
opportunity to now and wins one of the
best in the game yeah and not just
catching the passes but also blocking he
is one of the best in the game the wind
can't have that day but gate to win they
are two different kinds of play sure now
Whitley basketball but but man gates is
so crafty in small areas where win is
more of just a route disapproved guys
just got room
you did hear that Tony said he's the
greatest cowboy all the time right yes I
did hear that be false yeah I listen I I
don't mind Tony saying anything like
that about Jason win that's his guy I
was there you know early on when I
retire and I was sit out and go over to
the Kent Campus cuz it was retirement
was for me was very difficult so I would
go over there sometimes and just when
nobody was over there and just kind of
hang out at the facility I don't know I
was going through something but while I
was over there I always saw Tony Romo
jason wid coming off that field
just throwing that football to running
the floor in the football throwing
passes then I was like wow if that kid
ever breaks the old time record
interception record one day he would
earn it and he dat he does isn't it
incredible
Dallas is four in one right yes sitting
at the top of the NFC East with
Philadelphia they're balanced they're
finally getting that balanced attack
they're making sure Romo stays upright
they have a great offensive line and
we're still talking about how their home
field advantage is not a home-field
advantage there's always something going
on I know it did your Cowboys I know I
know herb that's why it's America's day
that's what
called America's Team we always want to
know what's going on but shouldn't
America's Team not let the rest of
America into their home well your house
where the where where where the
quarterbacks got to go silent snap yeah
and you know it's not listen it's
sometimes just like everything else you
know there is so much you know and I
thought it's outreach you know in some
places outside of this country they
considered Texas this America they
consider so that's how its America's
Team so people come into the stadium and
it's not just that they're rooting for
this they'll pay anything to get to that
stadium we call this part of seeing what
belongs to America's Team so so yeah so
yeah I'm not some kind of way to try to
get out of this if I could I know even
cuban cubans like saying that if i had
that problem with the mavericks I'd go
crazy let me tell you something
understated in the beginning of the year
the beginning of starting playing that
stadium and they were losing to the
Giants stuff I was ah I was hot man I
mean if you have a stadium like this and
you don't want to market with greatness
then people will market with what
they're marketing it with everybody else
is taking over your stadium right but
but at four and one you don't we're
falling one buddy
I can't let that crowd don't have the
way right what and even if you fall -
forward - I mean gobbler the for one not
we understand that you are you are
remember the paparazzi that you you can
you can bring in a level-headedness - 31
of the team's 32 you still wear a little
bit of the harder you know your heart I
understand that you can you can go ahead
and tell me why Seattle's gonna win the
game and it's entirely you can go ahead
and do that as analysts can do that
earth I could give you perspectives on
both sides I mean just I know that
really can't rich and it really can't
happen it because you know okay now
Cowboys have a running game and the
Cowboys are not this ridiculous offense
they are big play offense and the played
is Brian mate last week Hey
you can make that play anywhere if you
can make it there in Texas then you make
it anywhere in the world so those are
the things that can give Seattle a
problem but that running game the CIO is
a serious man with Marshawn mints and
person Harvin Harvin and the way they're
using them it's just incredible man with
Russell was yeah I mean there's gonna be
some more cowboys talk on tomorrow's
show Shireen Williams of the Fort Worth
star-telegram I believe she's on that I
love serene man yeah before you know
this lady she knows everything our Hall
of Fame list it's a female to vote she
worked to get me in the Hall of Fame do
that what that that's yeah she knows
everything about the Cowboys so she'll
be on the show Oh Dave Lapham of Bengals
radio will be on AJ green it looks like
it's not gonna be playing for quite some
time with it with a toe injury at least
not this weekend Andrew Siciliano is
gonna be the guest host for me because
I'm coming back from Houston that's on
Friday's edition of the Rich Eisen
podcast drew would you mind handing me
that jacket we want to make sure Chris
law Chris Brockman and Ted McCarran
you'll be on the show also do it you of
a minute this is it this is what you
call oh wait we've got that Daniel
Jeremias in studio tomorrow - okay you
see one tiny thing you can't even tell
oh and then a lot of model users can't
even tell right
you